[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: I am so proud to
welcome you all here today
for this very important
discussion that's
for the Decoding Race talk.
Over the past
couple of quarters,
the Race at Google team has
invited national leaders,
race experts, and
external luminaries
to guide us through many
similar conversations on race
and its intersections.
We're thrilled to bring
the event today to Atlanta,
covering the most important
topics of microaggressions
and bringing our
own selves to work.
Personally, I'm really glad to
see Google taking this subject
head on.
I think what we can all learn
by having the conversation,
by carving out the time
to be here will help us
at work and beyond and
will enable us to be better
to our peers and team members.
We've had a great
lineup for today.
And I'm thrilled to welcome
Fabiola Charles Stokes
and Michael Skolnik to talk us
through the agenda for today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Thank you.
So I learned a few lessons this
morning that I want to share.
First is I live in New
York City in Brooklyn.
I got up at 4
o'clock this morning.
And I cut my hair.
And I was not expecting
to speak today.
But I'm glad I cut
my hair because I
am going to speak today.
At least I have a hair cut.
That's the first lesson is
you never know when they're
going to call you to speak.
The second lesson is don't
take a nap on the airplane.
I never sleep on planes.
And when I took a nap on
the plane from New York
to Atlanta this
morning, I woke up.
And sadly two of
our panelists had
to cancel, one from New
York and one from Atlanta.
The great news is Kimberly got
in the plane from California.
So the one who came the
farthest didn't cancel.
I am going to--
this one, this one?
Either one.
CREW: Either one.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Fantastic.
I am going to lead
us in discussion
with Kimberly Papillon today.
Sadly, Sean and Theron
could not be with us today.
But we are going to have
an incredible discussion
on this topic.
And our sincere apologies
for their cancellation.
You now have me.
My sincerest apologies
for having me.
But we will have a really
robust conversation
and look forward to the Q&A
portion of the conversation,
so we can hear what you all
have to say and your thoughts.
Fabiola.
[APPLAUSE]
FABIOLA STOKES:
Thank you, Michael.
Luckily, we are all really
apt at thinking on our feet.
So we managed to switch
the format up just a little
bit this morning so that we
could ensure that we still
had a very robust
conversation and a dialogue
with our esteemed panelists.
So we are moving the
conversation event style
from a panel into more
of a fireside chat.
We'll have our two esteemed
thought leaders with us
who helped to drive the
conversation followed by what
we hope will be a very robust
Q&A from those Googlers
that we have here
with us in the room
as well as those
on the livestream.
So if you are watching from
afar, please log into the Dory.
Its go slash decoding
race hyphen Dory.
And drop in any questions that
you would like for us to share
and have answered for you today.
In addition, after
today's conversation,
please stay connected
with us on this issue
as well as others that
are being led by the team
by signing up for the
race at mailing lists.
So you can do those.
All the links for those are
in the emails in the invite
that we sent out for
the meeting today.
So in introducing our speakers
for this morning, first
we have with us
Michael Skolnik whom
we got to hear from a
little bit just before me.
Michael is the CEO of
SOZE, a creative agency
focused on social
impact campaigns
and triple bottom line
companies in addition
to being a renowned movement
builder, activist, storyteller,
and proud father.
He's a celebrated leader in the
new social justice movement,
who among other topics--
excuse me-- help to
ignite conversations
around America's
relationship with race,
the death of Trayvon Martin,
Mike Brown and Eric Garner,
as well as the Obama presidency.
He's a prolific voice on social
media with more than a quarter
million followers and a
regular commentator on outlets
such as CNN, MSNBC,
Fox News, NPR, and HLN.
From 2009 to 2015,
Michael served
as president of globalgrind.com,
a millennial-driven news
website founded by
Russell Simmons.
And he currently
serves on the board
of directors for the
Trayvon Martin Foundation,
the Drug Policy Alliance,
Revolutions Per Minute,
the Gathering for Justice,
and the Young Partner's
Board of the Public Theater.
Earlier in his career,
he spent over a decade
as an award-winning film
director and producer.
And we are glad to have
him with us here today.
Our second speaker for this
afternoon is Kimberly Papillon.
Kimberly is a nationally
recognized expert
on medical, legal, and
judicial decision making.
She has served as
regular faculty
at the National Judicial
College since 2005
and delivered over 400
lectures nationally
and internationally on the
implications of neuroscience,
psychology, and
implicit association
in the analysis
of decision making
in the fields of medicine,
business, education,
and the justice system.
If you think you're
in for a treat,
this is going to be a
really great conversation.
She has also lectured to judges
in over 20 states as well
as the United States Securities
and Exchange Commission,
the United States
Department of Justice,
and the US Department
of Education.
Kimberly is an attorney,
who previously served
as a senior educator for the
California Judicial Council
as well as represented Fortune
500 companies, government
entities, and tech startups.
She has a BA degree from
UC Berkeley and a JD
from Columbia University
School of Law.
So please join me in a rousing
welcome for our speakers today
as they help to lead
us through this really
critical and important
conversation.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SKOLNIK:
Thank you, Fabiola,
for those kind introductions.
I would-- you want the mic?
Because this is just
for the livestream, huh?
OK, so we can do mic.
So thank you for those
kind of introductions.
I would just give some quick
context to this conversation.
We have been brought on to
help curate these conversations
of the Decoding Race series.
This is now, I think,
our eleventh or twelfth
conversation that we've
had in this series.
And we're beginning
to dive deeper
into the conversations on race.
So this conversation
is going to be focused
around microaggressions
and bringing your most
authentic self to work
here at Google and folks
who are watching
around the country
and certainly for
those who will see it
on YouTube in a few weeks
from folks around the world.
So if we don't get to
a topic, race obviously
is a massive topic,
a big conversation,
a big challenge we
face in this country
and certainly around the world.
If we don't get to
a subject matter
that you thought we should
have talked about race,
we are trying to get to
those and other conversations
as well.
We have one of the great
experts on this subject matter
here with us today in Atlanta.
And we are going to have
a phenomenal conversation.
I just came from Washington
this past weekend
for the March for Science.
And I was the chair of the
board of the organization that
produced the Women's March.
So the Gathering for Justice
was founded by Harry Belafonte
10 years ago.
And I chaired the board
of that organization.
And that organization, we
brought the Women's March
into the organization.
And then we organized.
So Tamika Mallory, Carmen
Perez, Linda Sarsour, Bob Bland,
the four co-chairs of the March.
Three of them are part
of our organization.
And all three of them have
all spoken here at Google
as part of this series.
So I have now offered
our services for free
to the other marches that are
happening around this country.
And the Science March
had requested some help.
So I was in Washington
for the March for Science.
It was amazing to be
around so many scientists
and this conversation.
To really look at the science
of this, how the brain operates,
how when we see someone or meet
someone or hear someone's voice
or see someone's name
what happens to our brain.
And then how do
we act upon that.
So Kimberly, welcome.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Thank you.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: I know you took
a few planes to get here, too.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Yes, yes.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: So
thank you for being here.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Thank you.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: On behalf of
Google that I don't work for,
I'm thanking you on behalf of
all these beautiful people.
We don't get any
stock in the company.
But we do get a free lunch.
The lunch is always
good at Google.
So thank you for
having both of us.
Kimberly, if you
could just ground us
for a moment in
this conversation.
And we hear the term
microaggression a lot,
or we may not hear it at all.
Some of us might
know what it is.
Some of us may not
Can you just ground us in.
What is a microaggression?
How does it play out?
And then how do we recognize it?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Thank you.
Microaggressions, the term,
racial microaggressions,
was actually coined by
a man named Derald Wing
Sue from Columbia University.
But there's a way
to understand it
that I think is better than
just reading the definition out
of the book.
There's a really great
example for microaggressions.
Let's say you're
standing next to someone
who is much younger than you.
Let's say you're 20 years
older than they are.
And they're talking.
You're talking to them.
And they say no, I'm
trying to remember.
And they say, it's just on
the tip of their tongue.
They can't remember what
they were about to say.
It's just on the
tip of their tongue.
And a few minutes later, you
forget what you were saying.
And you say, I can't
remember what is.
And they say, are you
having a senior moment?
Now if you respond,
you're the problem.
That's a microaggressions,
where there's
a little bit of an insult,
a little bit of a statement
that you find problematic.
But, if you respond
you're the problem.
You think of the response
in the car on the way home.
You look in the rear
view mirror at yourself
and you say, if I had just said.
That's usually an
indication that there
was a microaggression afoot.
It's something that pokes at
you and, over a period of time,
can have a significant effect.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: So this place
is very unique as you all know.
You love VCs.
You love Google Hangout.
I've been on many of them.
Well, I'd love to walk through
is in a place like Google
how we meet somebody
from the very beginning--
a new employee, a new colleague,
a new person in your team.
You are spread out so
far around the world,
and you work so
closely with each other
on other campuses
across the world
that oftentimes you've never
met each other in person.
Oftentimes you're working
with a colleague in Mountain
View or a colleague overseas.
And you only meet that person
maybe once or twice a year.
But Kimberly, walk us through
when you hear someone's name.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
So for instance,
the first way you may meet
someone is through a name,
the name on the top of an
email; an announcement saying,
new employee is coming
to work; the participants
in a conference call; or a VC.
How does that name affect
the way that we think?
Well, before we go
there all the way,
I just want to mention
that we're talking
about unconscious processes.
We're talking about
things that go
on inside of the brain
that do not necessarily
comport with our
conscious value system.
They do not match the way
that we see ourselves.
They do not align
themselves with our goals
that they are unconscious.
Scientists theorize
that in a single second,
the conscious components
of the human brain
can process 40 frames
of information.
In a single second,
the conscious component
of the human brain can process
40 frames of information.
In that same second, the
unconscious components
of the human brain can
process 1.2 million frames
of information.
So who is really
running the show?
And some scientists theorize
that part of that 1.2 million
in the background drives
our decision making.
And part of that 40
in the foreground
is what we use to rationalize
our decisions or make us
feel better about our decisions.
So we want to try to
figure out what's going on,
comb through that data
in that 1.2 million.
And what's in a name is a
really good place to start.
So let's say I gave all
of us laptop computers.
And I told you all,
you're going to have
an email conversation with the
person in the room next door.
They're going to share
their math and verbal SAT
scores with you.
What might affect your
ability to recall those scores
once the conversation ends?
Well, that's exactly what a
group of folks at Harvard did.
They took a group of
undergrads, and they put them
in front of the computer.
And they said,
you're going to have
an email conversation with a
person in the room next door.
And the person in
the room next door
is actually an underpaid
graduate student, let's assume.
I know that's redundant.
But they're a graduate student.
Let's assume they're
given a script.
So every single
conversation is the same.
You and I, as the
undergrads, are
going to type in the questions.
We're going to send them
to the person next door.
The person next door is going
to have the same answers
to those questions.
So each and every
conversation is the same.
We need a variable.
How about the email addresses?
Some of the people are going
to get the email address
to reach the graduate student.
They're going to get the
email address, C-H-E-N, Chen,
C-H-E-N, @wjh.harvard.edu.
So basically chen@harvard.
The other people are going to
get Amy, A-M-Y, @harvard.edu.
Now they don't know
this is the variable.
They think everybody has
Chen, or everybody has Amy.
Conversation ensues.
Math and verbal SAT
scores are shared.
Conversation ends.
Proctor walks back
into the room and says,
do you recall the math
and the verbal SAT scores
that were shared with you?
So what do we think?
So let's say the person at
the email address, Chen,
do we think it's going to be
higher, lower, or the same?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Higher.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Higher?
What about Amy?
Higher, lower, or the same?
AUDIENCE: Lower.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Lower?
OK, so that's right.
So what people who
used the email address,
Chen, remembered the
math score as higher.
One to seven points
higher is our range.
People who had the
email address, Amy,
remembered it lower.
One to eight points lower
is our range for Amy.
What's going to
happen with verbal?
It flips.
People who used the email
address, Chen, remember
that individual
scoring lower in verbal
than what they were told.
People with the
email address, Amy,
remembered that person
scoring higher than
what they were told.
Now remember, the people who
had the email address, Amy, they
bring the score down for math.
Those are the same people that
upgrade that person in verbal.
And vice versa for Chen.
Oh, there's something
I forgot to tell you
about this particular study.
When each and every
one of the undergrads
walked into the
room, before they
typed a single key
on the computer,
they were all told
the exact same thing.
They were all told,
you are about to have
an email conversation with
an Asian-American woman
by the name of Amy Chen.
What do we do with that?
There's this notion
of what we call
perfect information
in this science
called game theory,
perfect information.
What if you have
perfect information?
What if you know everything
you need to know?
What if you have the resume
right in front of you
with the person's experience
and their schooling?
What if you have the
employee evaluations
right in front of you?
What if you have all
the emails of reports
that person has read?
What if you've
watched them at work?
Is it possible you
can misremember some
of the information-- not way
off, just a little askew--
to change the way that you
think about that individual.
So this is the notion
of having to template.
I have a template for how
somebody should perform,
what their character might be,
and what their skill set is.
And then they demonstrate
their skill set,
and they reveal their character.
But I might morph that
information to fit my template.
And that's one of
the concerns we have
because that's just
what's in a name.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Where
is that coming from?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: From
a number of places.
So the hippocampus
is the main part
of the brain that gathers and
stores data and information.
If we're talking
about a computer,
we would say data
collection and data
storage at the beginning
of the process.
So think of that data
collection and data
storage occurring in the
brain in the hippocampus.
And the possibility is that
the implicit association,
these unconscious thoughts,
affect our ability
to bring that data in and store
it correctly because it doesn't
fit our template.
So someone could come
in with great scores
and perform very well.
And we might recall
their mistakes
more clearly if they
fit our template
and fade out on some
of these successes.
Just downgrade
them a little bit.
I was giving a lecture to
a group of judges in DC.
One of them said,
you know, you don't
have to misremember
every single fact.
We couldn't have gotten at
this point in our careers
if we misremembered
every single fact.
You just have to misremember
every 10th fact or every 15th
fact-- and not way off,
just a little askew--
to change the trajectory of
the complex decision making
process.
In Google, people meet
each other all the time.
And so you have all of
this data coming in.
You don't have to skew
each and every one
of those pieces of data--
just every 10th or 15th,
and just a little bit off--
to change the overall
impression you
might have of that individual.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: So
then that individual
sends me, or gets
on my calendar,
because here at Google,
they can go in your calendar
to sign you up for VC.
So they sign you up for VC,
and then you see their face.
Talk to me about
seeing someone's
face for the first time and
how that affects our decision
making.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: So my
favorite part of the brain
is the part of the brain
called the amygdala.
Yes, I'm a big nerd to have
a favorite part of the brain.
But I want everyone to have a
favorite part of their brain.
So it's a part of the
brain called the amygdala.
And the amygdala is implicated
in fear, threat, anxiety,
and distress--
fear, threat,
anxiety, and distress.
They isolated the amygdala by
sliding people into the machine
and flashing pictures
of spiders and snakes.
And the amygdala lit up.
So they can't keep doing
these studies on the amygdala
because they'll never get tenure
if they just keep doing spiders
and snakes, right?
They've got to
kick it up a notch.
So they decide
they're going to flash
pictures of people's faces.
They're going to flash a picture
of a man of African descent
and a man of European descent.
And I'll use the short
for black and white
and African-American
and Caucasian,
but we don't know
their nationality.
We just know of African descent
and of European descent.
And they're flashing
the pictures.
They're going to
standardize the faces
for parts of the face that
make no difference to how
we tell who's of African and
who's of European descent.
Cheekbones, we don't use that.
Forehead size, chin,
that's not really
dispositive in determining that.
And they flashed the pictures.
They want us figure out
who are they can get more
of an amygdala activation for.
So what they find is
something interesting.
They get more of an
amygdala activation
for the African-American
man's face
than for the
Caucasian man's face.
Now there's probably a question
burning in the room right now.
Who was in the machine?
So they put only
Caucasian people
in the machine, who had been
living in the United States
for a full generation.
So that's the
information that they
were able to gather from that.
But what surprised
them actually was
that the level of
amygdala activation
matched directly with
people's scores on something
called the
implicit-association test.
So we can't all get
our brains scanned,
but we can all take the
implicit-association test
online.
And as people had more
trouble on the test matching
the idea of black
and good with faces
of people who were of African
descent and words like love
and pleasant and
things like that,
they were having more
trouble making that match
unconsciously.
They would have
more of an amygdala,
or spiders-like
activation, when viewing
the African-American man's face.
They kicked that up a
notch, too, by the way.
They took people
with different levels
of what we'll call
Afrocentric facial features,
including different, what
we'll call, skin shades.
Let me ask you a question.
On a scale of one to
nine, if I tell you
that Shaquille O'Neal
and Wesley Snipes
are a nine on the Afrocentric
facial feature range
and I tell you that
President Obama
is like a three on the
Afrocentric facial feature.
Where would Denzel Washington
fit on that scale, one to nine?
Because he's--
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Eight.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: You think so?
AUDIENCE: Four or five.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Wrong.
AUDIENCE: Six.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: 10.
AUDIENCE: Why 10?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
Denzel's always a 10.
[LAUGHING]
Are we correct about--
we can't move on before
we get unanimity on--
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: I'm
telling you, she's good.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
I'm just making sure.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: I told you.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
On this scale--
MICHAEL SKOLNIK:
Oh, man, she got me.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: --scale,
he'll be maybe a 5.5 or a 6.
Now let's take
all the people who
identify as African-American
off of that scale.
Let's put people who identify
as of European descent
or Caucasian on that scale.
We can have gradations
there, too, can't we?
As the skin becomes darker,
as the nose becomes broader,
starting from the top
as the lips become
more full, and the hair
it becomes curlier,
we can have more
one to nine scale
if we put people of European
descent only on that scale.
There's variations there.
Let's take them off.
Let's put people who are
Latino on that scale.
We're back to almost where we
would be with African-American
because we have to go
country by country by country
to be very specific.
We could put people who
are Asian on that scale,
couldn't we?
Asian-American or
Asian, correct?
And then we'd have a lot of
leeway in terms of skin color
at least in that conversation--
Pacific Islander,
Native American as well.
So what they found
is that as they
flashed-- in the United States.
This is US phenomena-- a
couple of other countries
still with this as well.
As they flashed pictures
of people with darker skin,
they were getting higher
levels of amygdala activation.
And they were flashing
pictures of people
in different ethnic groups.
So they were getting
this reaction.
So we can see that phenomena
of the spider-snake reaction
happening within
other ethnic groups
as well, particularly when
we look at, once again,
Latino and Asian.
We can see that occurring.
So this can manifest itself
in a number of different ways.
You see their face.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: One of
the common microaggressions
that we hear about
and talk about is
seeing an African-American
woman and saying,
can I touch your hair?
So seeing someone's, as a white
person, can I touch your hair.
And there's books
written about that,
that one question,
can I touch your hair.
And there was that
famous photograph
of President Obama
and the little boy
when he first came into office.
And the little boy
asked President Obama--
a young black boy
asked President Obama,
can I touch your hair?
Because he couldn't
believe the president
had the same hair as him.
So just on appearance, how
do microaggressions play out?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: That's
an excellent question.
Imagine walking in first for the
first time in meeting someone.
You watch the way
that they react.
Do their eyes become
big because they're
surprised because your
name didn't match the face?
Perhaps they were able to see
something that you had written.
Perhaps your title or
what you had written
didn't match the face again.
And that surprise may not
just be negative or positive,
but it may be an indication
to the person who's walking in
that that person has a
template, the person who's
viewing them has a template.
But it can also happen
in a meeting setting.
Let's say I decide
that I'm going
to be particularly verbose.
Or maybe I'm just
going to participate
in the meeting like anyone else.
Let's say I'm just going
to raise my hand when
the time comes and to
participate in the VC
like anyone else.
If you have a template of
me as being more aggressive,
then you may see my
basic assertiveness
and my contribution
as being overkill.
I'm oversharing.
Let's say I give a great idea.
I gave a great idea 10
minutes into the meeting.
And people say that
that's wonderful.
That's great.
But maybe it doesn't fit the
template you have for me.
20 minutes later, someone
else gives a similar idea.
And they say, Michael,
that was fantastic.
You need to be the head of
the subcommittee on that idea
because it seems like you could
run with that because that fits
the template that I have
once again for the face
or for the name.
The notion of the
touching of the hair--
there's a cultural competency
conversation in there, too.
It may not be that I'm saying
there's something negative when
I say I want to touch here.
But the notion of you
are so different, you
are so novel to me can be
disquieting to the person who's
saying, I want to
be part of the team.
I love my culture.
I value who I am.
But I also want you to see
me as part of this team
and not someone so novel
that you have to pay me.
If that makes sense?
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: You
talked earlier today
when I was speaking
with you with the idea
of dehumanizing somebody.
How does that land on somebody?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
That's really important.
So we do what's in a name.
We see what's in
a face on the VC.
That's the first thing
you're going to--
see the face-- and
then what's in a voice.
So we have a different
reaction to a pleasant
versus an unpleasant voice.
I was teaching a group
of judges in New York.
And they agreed that, yes,
Fran Drescher of The Nanny
would constitute an unpleasant
voice even for them.
Even though that
voice is familiar,
it can be seen as unpleasant.
And we can actually have
a different brain reaction
to that unpleasant voice.
But with voices, we also
have an additional reaction.
So what's in a name is the
hippocampus, the memory,
how do we collect data.
What's in a face, the amygdala.
What's in a voice, we're looking
at the caudate and the putamen.
We're looking at what we call
dehumanization but should
be termed as encoding
is fully human.
For me to see you
as fully human,
I need to see as both warm
and smart, nice and competent,
both of those things.
If I just see you
as competent, I'm
not encoding you in my
brain as fully human.
If I just see was
warm and empathetic,
I'm not encoding
you as fully human.
So what we're finding
is if I let you
listen to four separate voices.
One is going to be--
they're all going to
be accented voices--
one is going to be a
person with what they
call the Anglo-American accent.
And that's Nebraska, folks.
We required the
Nebraska accent of all
of our national male anchors
for news, not the women
and not the local anchors,
but the national male anchors.
So people will
take classes to try
to sound more Nebraska-like.
And so we've got that voice.
We'll get a "Harry Potter,
middle income" British,
not Beatles British, not
aristocratic British.
Then we'll get a native
Cantonese speaker And then
a native Spanish
speaker from Mexico.
And we're going to let you
listen to each of the voices.
What will your brain
do with the voices?
Well, we find that Harry
Potter and I'll say Dan Rather,
I believe is from Texas.
But he sounded like he was from
Nebraska when he took the desk.
We'll say that those
two individuals clearly
were encoded fully as warm and
smart, as nice and competent
on a human encoding scale.
The native Cantonese
speaker didn't score quite
as well for warm, but for
the native Spanish speaker
for Mexico, they
lost on both grounds,
both warm and competent.
So there are groups
that we may be
failing to encode in our brains
as fully human on both scales.
That'll reduce our
empathy for them.
That will change the way
we allocate resources.
That will alter the
way that we bring them
into the team,
the access they'll
have to have full contribution
making power into that team.
Can I say something?
Will it be heard?
Will it be valued?
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: I want to turn
to the audience for a second.
There's a lot of amazing
things coming in.
I don't want to do
a traditional just
we speak Q&A. I want to
take a moment to breathe.
And if there's any comments
or thoughts or questions
we have at this moment, I
certainly would welcome them.
So if anybody has any comments
or questions or thoughts,
the floor is yours.
If not, I'll continue.
But if you want to,
please raise your hand.
Don't be shy.
And we'll come back
to the audience.
I'm going to come out there
and do my Phil Donahue,
my Dan Rather with
not my raspy voice.
So back to the voice.
So you hear this voice, right?
You make judgment on his voice.
Where does the
microaggression come in?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Let's say
that your voice wasn't what
I was expecting in a number
of different respects.
Let's say I say to you, oh,
you speak English so well.
And your response is
yeah, I'm from Cleveland.
There shouldn't be
a surprise here.
But the notion that
you are surprised
or that I am surprised that you
are able to navigate English
as well as you do, the English
language as well as you do,
is an indication that that
wasn't my template for you.
Let's say--
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: There
were some conversations
when Barack Obama is running
for president how articulate he
was, that Barack was
so articulate even
by democrats, even by the man
who became his vice president.
He used that during a
debate that he is articulate
as if Barack Obama would be
anything different than being
articulate.
So those ideas of
judging someone
by their use of language, their
use of the English language
can lead to that
microaggression.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: And watch how
the microaggression works even
in that respect.
So each of those
microaggressions
were compliments.
If I say to you,
you're so articulate.
And you then give me some kind
of surprise, negative response,
then I say, what?
I just gave you a compliment.
What's the problem?
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Then
I become the problem.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
You're the problem.
You're playing the card,
whatever it might be.
And so the notion inside
of microaggressions
is that there's
a subtlety to it.
And the fact that
you were surprised
or that I was surprised
that you were articulate
was the insult or
the aggression.
But yes, it came in the
form of a compliment.
And so the person
who's speaking it aloud
doesn't believe that they're
saying anything other.
In fact, they may
have been building up
to finally want to say
something really nice to you.
And that's the thing
that they could think of,
and they tell you how
articulate you are.
So they are taken aback.
Now what you have is a
problem with perhaps some kind
of discontinuity in
the workplace because I
opened up and tried to
tell you something nice.
And you gave back
something that indicated
that I'd done something wrong.
Now I just want to shut down
and not have the conversation
anymore because
I don't even know
how to communicate with you.
I don't know how to even
give you a compliment.
So the recognition that maybe
I don't know everything there
is to know about communication.
Maybe I should step
back for a moment
and realize that some things may
mean something different to one
person versus another.
And a good way to
reflect on that
is to think what might
I find to be problematic
when people have said it to me
that I know other people say,
no big deal.
Let it go.
And that begins to
build the empathy.
Yes, there are things that are
specific to certain people that
perhaps are problematic for
me to say because it makes
it appear as if I'm surprised,
that they're doing that well,
that they are that able
to navigate English,
that they're that articulate,
those types of things.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: So let
me answer a question.
And we'll come back to
meeting this new person.
I'm not a HR person.
So I was a theater major
for full disclosure.
So we are not here to
have an HR discussion.
Those are for other kinds of
professionals who do HR work.
When this conversation
of microaggressions
was proposed as
part of the series,
there are many folks who
Google said, yes, this
is the conversation
we need to have.
Folks who are shaking their
head in your audience,
I won't look in that direction.
But I see some head nods.
This is the conversation
we need to have.
There are also folks
at Google who say,
we actually have a really
healthy work environment here.
I've heard words like family.
I've heard words
like this is home.
I've been to now
15 Google campuses,
and I see an
amazing camaraderie.
I see some folks who I met,
who came from the data center.
This is their second time here.
Welcome back.
There is a sense of
wearing Google with pride.
I'm a Googler.
It's a way to identify yourself.
But yeah, this
conversation oftentimes--
and we're not trying to
open up a can of worms--
but oftentimes gets shut down
as being politically correct.
And certainly in this last
presidential election,
those words are
being thrown around.
Oh, they're just being
politically correct.
Political correctness is the
reason we have this problem.
And then I hear oftentimes
a criticism for me--
if you stop talking about
race, racism will go away.
But you're the problem
because you're always
talking about race.
So how do we have
these conversations
in a healthy
environment but that
are honest and that
if someone said,
can touch my hair,
that might hurt me.
And I don't understand,
as you said,
how that hurts that person.
How does that translate
into a conversation
that is productive?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: That
makes a lot of sense.
Political correctness is a term
that I think, you're right,
has been a bit demonized.
We'll challenge Google to
come up with a new term.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Good idea.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: I think
that there are certainly
able to do so.
I'll wait to see that
news blast at any moment.
But I will say this--
microaggressions
have health effects,
long-term and short-term
health effects.
And there are a number of
studies that show that.
Long-term, what we call
epigenetic health effects,
changes in cortisol release,
long-term chronic disease
effects.
So the people who
are on the receiving
end of microaggressions
constantly over and over
again--
because you can't really
speak about them out loud,
because you can't
really voice them,
and often you try to tell
yourself to ignore them,
they seem to have a physiologic
effect on an individual's
health.
So it's not just simply can
we be more polite, which
fork do you pick up, the kind
of Emily Post-type conversation.
It really goes deeper than that.
It goes to do I feel
as if I belong here.
And how does that affect
me as a person who's
trying to work in an
environment that I really love,
where I really want to be
productive and contribute
to the team, which is part of
the essence of a conversation
at Google in my opinion.
So they've got a
study that shows
if you feel someone's
treating you unfairly,
a part of your brain called
the insula activates.
And the insula is the
same part of the brain
that turns on when you
smell rotten garbage.
That's an effect,
then, if I constantly
believe I'm being treated
unfairly, small or large
incidents.
There's another study,
study at Stanford,
and it kills me to say that.
Go Bears.
So they take 10 people,
put them all in a row,
and they tell them
you're going to pass
a ball around, one ball.
And they say to 9
of the 10 people,
don't give the ball
to person number 10.
No problem.
Person number 10 has no
idea what's going on.
They pass the ball around
and pass the ball around
and pass the ball around.
And then they take person number
10 and they scan their brain.
And they find that
person number 10
has the same brain
reaction as if they've
been punched in the gut.
Now that's different from
getting punched in the arm.
That's a pain conversation.
But the part that's
unique to getting
punched in the gut, the anxiety,
the helplessness, the panic,
the fear, that is unique to
the gut punch, getting the wind
knocked out of you.
So there are people walking
around the workplace who
feel like they can
smell rotten garbage
and they got punched in the gut.
That's got to really
reduce productivity.
That's beyond the idea
of were we polite.
That's the notion
of is someone having
a neurophysiologic
reaction to being
seen as other or less than.
And can I touch your
hair says other.
And you are so articulate, in a
surprised way, says less than.
And in an organization
that wants nothing
but the best from all
of their employees,
nothing but the highest
level of productivity
and creativity at
that, you really
want to foster an
environment where
people feel when
they walk in the door
that they're there to belong.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK:
So I'm a white man.
And I don't think I'm racist.
And I think I have
black friends.
And I support Black
History Month.
And I voted for Barack Obama.
But yet I find
myself in a meeting--
if I take a step back, oh,
I'm judging you as a woman.
Or I'm judging you
as a black man.
And how do I find
a solution for me
as an individual in the
workplace to not be the one who
says, can I touch your hair?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Well,
one of the first steps
is to reduce what we call the
level of moral credentialing.
So I voted for Barack Obama.
I vote for President Obama.
Some of my best friends are
fill in the blank, whatever
it might be.
Those create a reaction called
moral credentialing, which
is the brain reaction that's
akin to eating chocolate.
I feel rewarded.
And I reward myself.
And whenever I come
into a situation
where I think I might
mess up, I remind myself
of the individuals who
I've reached out to,
the young person that
I tutored at the school
down the street,
all those people.
That gives me a
better sense of I
couldn't possibly have this
simplistic negative association
in play.
And that actually keeps
me from doing the work
that I need to do to undo that
so-called unconscious bias
because I tell myself it
couldn't have affected me
because some of my best
friends are fill in the blank.
That is actually a barrier
to getting to a solution.
And the reason we
give it to ourselves
is because people's value
system is I want to be fair.
And when they see the spectrum
of unfairness raised, they say,
let me remind myself of
how I'm definitely fair.
I get that chocolate feeling.
And now I can just
go on with my day.
So if we can remove
the notion of needing
to have the moral
credentialing, saying it's OK.
This is a human reaction.
It's not OK if it
manifests itself
in a way that hurts people.
But the fact that I
have these templates,
this is something
that came into my mind
when I was watching
Saturday morning cartoons.
In the '50s, in the
'60s, the accent given
to the bad guy in most children
shows was Russian and German.
You grew up during that time,
Russian and German, that's
the sound of the bad guy.
In the '70s, we get
aristocratic British
as the mastermind bad guy
and African-American ebonics.
Ebonics is an antiquated term.
If you're listening to a voice
and as you're listening to it,
you can definitely tell that
the person who was speaking
is African-American or the
rapper Eminem, either way,
that's African-American ebonics.
And then in the 1980s, we
add on a Latino accent.
And there's multiple Latino
accents, so mostly Colombian,
Puerto Rican, Mexican-American.
Those will be the three
that we'll add in.
And those are loose terms.
And we find that these
become the villains.
And we can look at
all kinds of examples,
including even the
Lion King, where
Scar is a lion on the African
desert, who was apparently
educated at Oxford.
And we're thinking, why is
this lion, who's the bad--
but he's the mastermind bad guy.
So we're replete
with these examples.
Our brains are like
heat-seeking missiles.
We're looking for templates.
And so if we can
get past the guilt
and stop dealing with
the moral credentialing
and move onto the solution,
then we're on our way.
And the solutions are based
in the neuroscience, too,
of course.
If I'm the manager and
I'm sitting in a meeting
and I want to look at how
many times certain people are
being interrupted over others,
I might not tell anybody.
I'm not going to point
out which employees
are doing the interrupting.
I'm just going to note who gets
interrupted more frequently.
And then afterwards,
I have the meeting.
I say to everybody,
look, I'm going
to be watching
whether or not we're
letting people
finish their thoughts
and whether or not we're
encouraging people to share
inside of that meeting.
Well, now there's a
part of my brain called
the rostral anterior
cingulate cortex that's
going to turn on whenever
I think I'm being monitored
for race-related bias.
My manager is not saying
it's going to be punitive.
They're just saying, I'm
paying attention to this.
I want us to do better.
Now what if I start
self-monitoring.
I don't need my manager, right?
I can self-monitor.
I'm going to note how
frequently I interrupt
one person versus another.
As soon as I start noting
it, my RACC turns on,
and I stop interrupting people,
at least not as frequently
one to the other.
So the solutions are
based on the neuroscience.
What part of the brain
do you need to turn on.
When I give my
lectures, I tell people,
the thesis of the
conversation is getting back
control of your brain.
If there's 1.2 million
in the background that
is guiding our
decision-making and it
doesn't align with
your value system,
you need to get control
of your brain back.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: So our first
conversation that we had with--
I actually was on the panel
with [INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
We're in New York.
I think, Dory, you were there.
And there was a
young woman sitting
in the front, a young
African-American woman sitting
in the front.
And she had a T-shirt on.
And the T-shirt had the
names of the victims
of police brutality.
And afterwards I said to
her, do you feel comfortable
wearing that T-shirt to work?
And she says, I do, but I
get asked a lot of questions.
What does that mean?
Why are you wearing that?
Who are those people?
What do the names represent?
So bringing your
most authentic self
to work, how do
we do that with--
and I'm saying me not be part
of the we as a white male who is
never judged with how I dress
or what I have on my T-shirt--
But how we, for
those who are judged
or those who are
asked questions,
how do we bring our most
authentic selves to work
with pride and without
fear of retribution
or fear of punishment or fear
of getting asked a question over
and over again about your
hair or about your T-shirt
or about the way you speak or
about the way your name is?
How can someone in
this room or who's
watching on the livestream
bring their most authentic self
to work and still feel like they
can have a job the next day?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: That's
an excellent question
because we want that.
If I feel comfortable,
I'm more creative.
Now there's some places where
we don't encourage creativity.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: I love that.
Say that again.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: If I feel
comfortable, I'm more creative.
And in those places where we
don't encourage creativity,
then we can say, perhaps bring
your authentic self to work
isn't as much of
a value in terms
of the bottom line for the
organization or the company.
But if we're looking
for creativity,
if we're looking for
innovation, doing that
is difficult in a
stressful environment.
When I have an
amygdala activation,
let's say I'm just
scared of being myself.
I have to constantly
be on my Ps and Qs,
an amygdala activation
actually depletes
the executive
functioning of the brain.
So we want to be really
careful to try to make
people feel comfortable.
Now we're not
running Google Camp.
This isn't a place for
everybody to learn how to play.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: A little bit.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
A little bit, right?
We don't all have to hold
hands and sing "Kumbaya."
But we do want to have
a situation where people
feel like, I can wear this.
It is appropriate in the office.
But I won't be judged
negatively for it.
People might ask questions.
And I can explain
it and not feel
as if I have to edit every
single term that I use.
And that's what we want.
And how to get that going--
leadership.
These kinds of conversations.
Saying that this is an important
conversation for everyone
to be having.
And we want you to be
comfortable having it.
Number two,
indictment goes down.
We all have these various
ideas in our heads.
Let's try to work
with them together.
Number three, education.
It's not a small thing.
But learning about
one another so you
don't have to get
your colleague, who
fits in a particular
category, to be the professor
on all things Latino.
And suddenly they
have to tell you
all about all things Latino.
And they're thinking
that I don't think
that's in my job description.
So that distracts from what
they would be doing that day.
It goes beyond the potluck.
But leadership saying, we
care about these things
and putting mechanisms in
place to make sure that that
is part of the value system.
There is software that Google
can put in place to make sure
that people are all
getting a, quote
unquote, "fair opportunity for
certain types of assignments."
There are images that can be put
up inside of the workplace that
demonstrate a certain
value for equity,
that anyone can work
this particular job
and look at the different
faces that are working
in this particular job.
Those types of conversations
are powerful because they're
the same things that imprinted
us in the first place
when we were children.
These ideas of black,
good, white, bad,
this is not universal.
This is learned behavior.
We're not born this way.
We come to it through
images, through messages
from all different portals.
And so we have a way
to unlearn it as well.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: I would
love to turn to a reader
the audience who wants
to ask a question.
This gentleman in the back
with the beautiful shirt on.
I love everyone's shirts today.
I think I've got to give you
a microphone so our friends--
come on up.
The price is right.
Spin the wheel!
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you, sir.
Several things you said
bring up the same question
in my mind, which
is if you're going
to get control of
your behavior, then
you need to know
what you should do.
And many of these issues
around microaggressions,
such as the example where
you had different assignments
to different people, if you
want to recognize someone,
how do you avoid-- you
can overdo it, right?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Right.
AUDIENCE: And that also makes
someone feel as though you're
patronizing them.
And so how do you
build the model
for what you should do without
messing it up along the way?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: That
is an excellent question.
That's an excellent question.
So the first step in the
12-step program for solution
is admit you have a problem.
It just happened that way.
Admit that implicit bias
exist or unconscious bias
or negative associations
exist and that they affect
your everyday decision-making,
that not implicit bias
exist, and you really need
to talk to my colleagues.
We're not there yet.
It's implicit bias
exists, and it affects
my everyday decision-making.
But number two in our 12-step
program is take the test.
Go on, and take the
implicit-association test.
As your attorney, I tell you
not to print the results out
and bring them back
to your colleagues.
This is for your
own edification.
But go online,
and take the test.
And see where your
challenges might lie.
They might not lie
where you think.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: --called
google.com, I'd Google what?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: Right.
So you go implicit-association
tests or IAT Harvard.
Harvard wants to make sure
they get their name in there.
All right, so
either one of those.
And then you go on, and you
can go ahead and take the test
and take multiple tests.
Take the sexual
orientation test.
Take the weight test.
Take the religion test.
Take the gender-science test.
Do we have a difficulty with
matching up the idea of woman
with the hard sciences?
So take those tests.
There's a gender
career test as well.
Do female in career not match
as well as male and career?
Those conversations.
So those are great
tests to take.
Then how can I
actually look through
and monitor my own behavior?
Is there a template?
We don't necessarily want
people to start creating scripts
because that doesn't go for
the flow of the workplace.
But recognize that we might
look at people differently.
And a good way to bring
them into the circle
is to do what we call
making them our Bob.
It's a study called Bob and Jim.
So they're going to
bring you in a room.
Call your lawyer soon as
they bring you in the room
because that there's-- a
study's about to begin.
And you're going to need
some forms to be signed off.
So you walk into the room.
They're going to give you a
picture of two people, Bob
and Jim.
Now Bob and Jim
are both white men.
Their eyes are equidistant
from the center.
Their ears are the same
in terms of how close they
are to the head.
Their expression is
180 degrees across,
eyes, all of those things.
They couldn't be
brothers, but they
might be cousins, Bob and Jim.
And they're going to say
underneath the picture of Bob
and underneath the
picture of Jim,
they're going to put
some stereotypes for you.
So underneath the
picture Bob, they're
going to say Bob is
from the Midwest.
He's an evangelical Christian.
He's a registered Republican.
And he considers himself
to be conservative.
Got your stereotype for Bob?
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Mm-hmm.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
OK, hold onto that.
Next they've got Jim.
Jim is from the East Coast.
He's Christian but not
particularly regular
in his religious practice.
He's a registered democrat.
He considers himself
to be liberal.
Stereotype for Jim?
Now they don't care that
they built the stereotypes.
They care about
what happens next.
They want you to pick who
you're more like, Bob or Jim.
Doesn't matter who you pick.
This is not about being
conservative or liberal.
It's about who's most like you.
So let's say I pick Bob.
Now they're going
to ask me deep,
meaningful, sociopolitical
questions about Bob,
like does Bob like Oreo cookies?
Does Bob do his
laundry once a week?
Does Bob want to go home to see
his family for Thanksgiving?
Does Bob like to tell the truth?
And when they ask me these
questions, they scan my brain.
And as I think
about and judge Bob,
they find that a
part of my brain,
called the ventral
prefrontal cortex, lights up,
the vmPFC lights up when I
think about and judge Bob.
Keep me in the
machine another round.
They say, professor,
oh, now we want
to ask you the same
questions in the same order
but this time about Jim.
Does Jim like Oreo cookies?
Does he like to tell the truth?
And they find that my dorsal,
not my ventral, but my dorsal
medial PFC lights up when I
think about and judge Jim, when
I assess his habits, when
I predict his preferences,
when I analyze his character.
A different part of my anatomy
lights up when I judge Jim,
the person who I
said is not like me.
Now if you said Jim
was like you, then
this reaction would
happen for Bob.
So once again, it's not
about political proclivity.
They need a little
more grant money,
so they keep it in the
machine one more time.
And they say,
they're going to ask
me the same questions
in the same order
but this time about myself.
Do I like Oreo cookies?
Do I like to tell the truth?
And they find that
my ventral, not
my dorsal, but my
ventromedial PFC,
the same part of the
brain that lit up
for the person who was
like me, lights up when
I think about and judge myself.
Have you ever made a mistake?
Don't answer that question.
When you make mistakes, do you
look in the mirror and say,
I am evil to the core.
I am beyond redemption.
There is no state or county
program that can help me now.
No, you look in the mirror
you say, if I had more time,
I would have done a better job--
more resources, more
training, more support.
If the person had gotten this
project before me had not
completely messed it up
before they put it on my desk,
I would have done a better job.
That's the Bob reaction.
That's the ventral
medial prefrontal
cortex working to
let us give ourselves
the benefit of the doubt.
And we lend it to our
Bobs and not to our Jims.
So one of the next parts
in the solution set
is to make people our Bobs,
to connect to people so that--
they may never get
to our original Bob.
But we will feel like
they're more like us.
And then we will
be more comfortable
having the
conversations with them.
And there's a lot of
things to bring out--
in quick conversations, you
can create some small amount
of Bob reaction-- dog
versus cat people, team
that you like, sports team
that you like, hometown.
Things like that kick in.
But for long-term relationships,
integrated relationships,
where you're able to
talk to people on the VC
over and over again, you
can build even more detail
into that Bob template
so that people,
you're seeing them as more,
quote unquote, like you.
And you remove this notion
of who's good and who's bad.
Can I tell you one more
solution to match with--
this one I love.
They take a group of
people, and they give them
the IAT, a bias-related
test, ahead of time.
Then they have them
play flag football.
Then they give them
the IAT afterwards.
And their race level
of bias goes down.
So what did they do?
What they did is they
had team A and team
B, two different ethnic groups.
And they took a person who was
A and made them play on team B.
Now that person has to cooperate
and collaborate with people
who are like them and
compete against people
who are like them.
So cooperate and
collaborate with people
who are not like them and
compete against people
who are like them.
Now what happens?
They begin to remove that
line between what's us
and what's them.
They don't lose
their appreciation
for their original
teammate, their culture,
their background, their history,
but they add on a new team.
This is my team, too.
And that creates a different
notion of me versus them,
us versus them, and it brings
down your level of bias.
Now that means that
you'd have to be
the only person
on that team that
has that particular identity.
It's not a bad exercise.
It's not a bad thing to do in
a virtual reality environment.
It's not a bad thing to do
in an actual play session
that you would be
able to put together.
But that team building
stuff that people
think is so touchy-feely,
if it's mechanized
so that it begins
to affect the brain
and that these neural
reactions, then we can actually
create a different notion
of who's us, who's them,
and then we start to
treat people the way
we would want to be
treated as opposed to gosh,
you seem so interesting.
Can I touch your hair?
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: I think we
have a question from Dory.
Fabiola?
Is that where you're going?
FABIOLA STOKES: Yes,
that's where we're going.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Going to Dory.
FABIOLA STOKES:
Lots of great tips.
And we're going to take a couple
of questions from the Dory.
So the first of these is--
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: The Dory,
by the way, just so you know,
is folks around the country and
the world can ask a question
into [INAUDIBLE].
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: So
we'll look at the--
FABIOLA STOKES:
The first of these
is can you suggest
tactful ways to respond
to microaggressions
that are in the spirit
of a teachable moment?
So with the goal
of helping a person
understand that they're
making a microaggression
and why they should not
perhaps do that in the future
or how they can
change their behavior.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
That is best done
in an environment where people
are speaking the same language.
So the nomenclature,
microaggression,
if everyone knows what that
means and everybody knows what
implicit bias or
implicit association
is and people know that this
is an unconscious process,
then when someone engages
in a microaggression,
you can say, now that might have
been a little microaggressive,
and I know you did need that.
Allow me to share
something with you.
You can't do that in an
environment where people
aren't speaking that same
language because all they hear
is you're calling me an -ist--
sexist, racist, ageist.
So that's not the
conversation we're having.
We're having a conversation
about unconscious thoughts.
So getting everyone onboard,
having everyone not just
learning about it
in the surface way
but have it become
part of the dialogue.
And that's the feedback
that I get back a lot.
If I teach a group repeatedly
and with other individuals
as well who go back and
teach groups repeatedly,
they find that they get feedback
that a couple of months later,
the conversation in their
meetings has changed.
They are more comfortable
saying, now hold on a second,
was that a gender interruption?
That happens inside
of the meeting.
Let's think about that.
Was there some
implicit association
there in our assumption of
who was more or less qualified
as they're making
hiring decisions?
And it doesn't feel
like an indictment.
It feels like, OK,
we're just including
that in the analytical
process of how we think.
That's a safe space to be in.
And what curious
people like at Google
and intelligent people
who want to engage
in that analytical process,
adding an additional factor
shouldn't be scary.
It should be like, OK, now
we've got more complexity.
Now we're going to
be more thorough.
FABIOLA STOKES: Great.
Great.
So Michael has sat onstage
with us today as an ally
and has talked a
lot about his work
in partnership with a
number of organizations.
Can you tell us a
little bit about what
some of the common
misconceptions
are of allies or
others who really
want to be helpful as
a part of this dialogue
and what you wish
they knew to be
able to mitigate against
potential issues in the future
and really become great partners
as we work together in that?
So this is both of you can.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: I would
just tell one quick story.
I teach race to white
teachers of how to teach
their students about race.
Most teachers in this
country are white women.
And many of them teach
children of color.
And in the moment that
we're able to discuss this
over some food earlier,
the advents of what you all
have created, these devices
in everyone's pocket,
and the communication change
in this country in the past 10
years has brought the crises
of race in the immediate.
So a child may come into school.
And that morning, someone
might have been shot
in his or her neighborhood.
And they want to talk about it.
And teachers are
often unequipped
to have those kinds
of conversations.
Or there might be a big
verdict over the weekend
or a nonindictment.
And they're having
protests in the streets.
And the child's parents
might be in the protest,
during the protest, and
they want to talk about it.
So one exercise that we
do with white teachers is
whenever let down
or not been there
for a young black boy or girl?
And we're teaching a
school in New York,
and it's a private school.
And we bring in teachers
and administrators.
And people work in the
kitchen and all kinds of us.
It's a white affinity group.
And we go around the room.
Everyone expresses when
they've let down somebody who's
a young black boy or girl.
And this one man.
Who happened to be
in the IT department,
he says, I hate this question.
I'm not answering this question.
This question is bull--
I said, OK.
Pass the mic.
You don't have to
answer the question.
I'm not racist.
My partner in my IT
department is black.
He's my best friend,
and I'm not racist.
I said, OK, pass the mic.
Next question.
Then he starts sobbing like
a child, bawling like a baby.
I said, what's going on?
My whole life I've used the
excuse of not being racist.
And I've never shown
up for young black boys
and black girls.
I always thought I
wasn't the problem,
so I don't have to do the work.
That moment for me,
as an ally, made
me want to dig
deeper into the work
amongst my white peers
and my white colleagues
and my white family.
And how do we dig deeper
into the work and show up?
And so for those who are in
the room today, proud of you
to come to this because we've
been at many other campuses
across Google.
And it's not as racially
diverse as this room, especially
other topics of conversation.
But after I'm proud of
you, as your white ally,
I also challenge you to go back
to your stasis in this building
and across [INAUDIBLE]
data center
if you're coming from over there
and talk to white colleagues
of what you learned today
or why they didn't come.
Now some may have meetings
or out of town or travelling,
but some may be down the hallway
or across the hallway having
lunch.
And this wasn't for them.
So those are conversations as
white allies and white people
we have to have with each other.
Oftentimes I heard from many
people during the election
after Trump won the election
that they didn't want
to go home for Thanksgiving.
They didn't want to have the
conversation with a family
member who had voted for Trump.
But those conversations,
those courageous conversations
we have had.
And so for that question,
where that question's
coming from as an ally,
the first step for me
is just showing up.
And for many of
you, this might be
the first time
you've been involved
in a conversation like this.
Or this might be your ten
thousandth conversation.
But you're here today,
and that matters.
That matters in this building.
Folks of color in
this room see you.
They may not know
you, but they see you.
They see me.
They say, OK, maybe
next week when
I see that person
in the cafeteria,
I've never met
that person before.
But I can start a conversation
based on the shared
experience we all had today.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
That was powerful.
I often say, the
most difficult people
to teach fairness to are people
who value fairness the most.
I'll say it again.
The most difficult people
to teach fairness to
are people who value
fairness the most.
If you really care about
fairness, if you really
care about equity, these
types of conversations
can be painful.
These types of conversations
can be disquieting.
If we had the
PowerPoint slides up
and we're going through
each of the studies one
after the other, somebody proved
to you in a rigorous fashion
that implicit bias exists
and that it affects
your everyday decision-making
is not a comfortable place
to be in if you value fairness.
And so there is a rebound
effect, this notion of I
don't want to hear this
because it's painful.
The reason it's
painful is because I
value fairness so highly.
So getting past that notion
of yes, this is uncomfortable.
But there is such extraordinary
reward in doing the work.
And it's not what works solely
for the notion of someone else.
That's what makes it hard,
the notion of someone else.
It's not the idea of I'm going
to build a home for someone
else in a completely different
environment in a completely
different community.
I'll probably never
drive by this home again.
It feels good to have
completed this structure
and help someone.
But I probably won't
even meet the person
who moves into that home.
It's not that.
It's not that at Google.
It's the notion of I am going
to change the way that I
take in information.
I am going to regain
control of my own brain.
Why?
Because I don't want to
undervalue innovation coming
from one person versus another.
That affects my ability
to make good judgments
and good decisions.
I don't want to skip
over ideas because they
came from that voice as
opposed to another voice.
I don't want to discount
talent because the name
at the top of the email or the
resume wasn't what I expected.
That actually is not just
affecting the bottom line.
That's affecting my ability
to do what I want to do.
And if I want to not just
build a better society,
but I want to build a
better workplace for me,
then I want to join
in that process.
You can have lots
of friends of color.
We haven't found that having
one or two or even four or five
friends who are of a
different ethnicity
lowers your level
of implicit bias.
What we find is that
we make that person
feel like they're one of us.
We do a Bob on them,
which is a good thing.
But we want to do that
in a more grand sense.
But if we only do that for a
few people, bring them in, what
happens is we
maintain our template
for all of the people, who are
also part of that community.
We just pull out an exception.
You've heard
somebody say, you're
an honorary fill in the blank.
That means that they
made you one of them
but forgot to change the
template for what they
have for the outside group.
So that is the next step,
bringing everybody in.
It's the first, or I
should say, third step.
But that next step is let me
change the template that I
have for the outside group.
That requires reading.
That requires education.
That requires recognizing that
some of the things that we see,
be it on the news or reading
the books or seen on television,
may not be actual
indications of truth.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Two more.
I want to respect people's time.
And it's the middle of the week.
And a courageous
Googler from Atlanta
has a question somewhere
in the audience?
Are we to go to the Dory?
AUDIENCE: I think
you've got an answer.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: We
have a woman here.
Come on up.
Thank you for your courage.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Hello.
So my question is how do
we celebrate differences
and diversity without creating
microaggressions and things
like that?
If I tell someone, oh, your hair
looks nice or something like
that because it's different
than what my hair is like
or something, how do we
celebrate those differences
and have a culture of
celebration of the diversity as
opposed to microaggressions?
KIMBERLY PAPILLON:
Great question.
I think saying,
your hair is nice,
I like that shirt,
those types of things
aren't going to be seen
as microaggressions.
Once again, it's
the can I touch it
because it's so different as
opposed to I can appreciate it.
So actually what you said was
a celebration of the diversity.
And I think number one,
celebrating includes
recognizing that we get
more and more and more
information about
various individuals.
People always use holidays
as a way to celebrate it.
We're going to do something
on Black History Month.
But there is a more rigorous
way to go about that.
Celebrating individuals
who have achieved
in various areas of
technology and business,
giving some historical
perspective.
It is definitely helpful
for managers and supervisors
to check and see are they
giving kudos all the same level
to everybody across the board.
Is everybody getting
the same clapping
at the end of the meeting?
Is it being mentioned
when somebody
does a good job in each and
every respect across the board?
If we're not going to mention
certain kinds of achievement,
we should not mention
them for everyone.
If we're going to
mention them, we
should mention them for
everyone across the board.
Celebration doesn't come first.
Genuine celebration that's
helpful doesn't come first.
Celebration that's helpful comes
after understanding is in place
and after the
templates begin to be
removed because then it truly is
celebration instead of novelty.
So your question is excellent.
But we usually start
with celebration.
I think that that's going
to move into understanding.
But what we're finding
is that understanding
needs to come first,
which means we need
to learn about one another.
But we also need to
monitor our own behavior.
I might never know about
people from Brooklyn.
It may never happen.
I could still see you as--
I can encode you as fully human.
I can take your ideas and
give them value and wait
across the board
with equity if I
am able to recognize
that I might have a bias
and I need to not
morally credential myself
and I need to recognize
what makes you valuable.
I don't need to know about
your favorite holiday
to get that right.
And if there's a
culture and leadership
has a culture of
inclusion and says,
we're going to treat everybody
the same in the meeting.
I'm going to monitor
this process.
I'm not necessarily
being punitive.
I'm saying that this is
important because this
is what drives innovation.
This is part of the culture
of this organization,
that we are about
driving innovation.
And we cannot have innovation
when people are stagnated.
And so we've got to make sure
that those meetings have more
meaning and that we're able to
open them up so that everybody
who is considered talented, and
assuming you wouldn't be here
if you weren't talented, so
that everybody is considered
talented can actually
contribute in a meaningful way.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: This
has been incredible.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: I do have a question.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: Oh, fantastic.
Come on up.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thank you.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK:
I like your shoes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
by the way.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: There you go.
AUDIENCE: They're comfortable.
So we're talking about
celebration oftentimes comes
first.
I wonder sometimes, do
we have to care first?
Because I feel like when I
look out in the audience,
I'm preaching to the
choir at a point.
And sometimes I
struggle with how do we
expand the conversation?
But I don't think
we can really, truly
do that if people don't care.
So how we get people
to care a bit deeper?
Number one just for this group.
And then I'm also
wondering, [INAUDIBLE]
spend time with judges?
And you talked about
those four things
I can't remember-- competent,
nice, and et cetera.
And it has to do
with whether or not
they care about people and
how it might impact synthesis
and things like that.
I'm just curious to know
where does caring come
into the picture, if at all.
KIMBERLY PAPILLON: We think
caring is linked primarily
to the notion of empathy
and helping behavior.
And I like to also
think that empathy
comes after understanding.
So there is a
pain-empathy reaction
called corticospinal inhibition,
corticospinal inhibition.
When you get hurt,
a numbing sensation
runs down to that
area that got hurt.
You don't think that it
does, but if it does.
Otherwise it would
hurt much more.
But if I see somebody who
I care about get hurt,
I don't get the pain reaction.
But I get the same
numbing sensation
to that part of the body
where they were injured.
And sometimes you can feel it.
You get a tingle up your
spine in a horror movie.
Or you see a child fall
down and hurt their knee,
and you grab your
knee and say, ouch.
That must have hurt,
those kinds of things.
So what we're finding
is that if people
are looking at
hand that does not
appear to look like
their own and we
poke that hand with
a hypodermic needle,
they're having a cortical spinal
inhibition for the hand that
looks like they're own, a
pain-empathy, physiologic
reaction we can measure, a
lack of one for the hand that
doesn't look like theirs,
and a little bit of pain
reaction among those who
are considered Caucasian
in the United States
were finding they have
a little bit of a pain reaction
for the purple hand, the Barney
hand we like to call it.
That needs to be studied
more, the Barney phenomenon.
We're working on that one.
But what's interesting
is that if we can create
an empathetic reaction
for other individuals,
then we can increase the caring.
And what they found was if
they put somebody's hand
behind a little curtain and
they put a little monitor
right above the hand,
and they show you
a picture of a hand that
doesn't look like yours--
different skin color--
and they slowly
brush on the top of that hand
in the movie or in the film,
slowly brush it back and
forth on the top with a brush.
And then your hand is
behind the curtain.
And somebody does
the same thing to you
in exactly the same
rhythm with a brush.
You begin to lower your
level of implicit bias.
You begin to take on the notion
of oh, that's like my own hand.
It changes that neuroreaction.
So it's different from
just saying I want
to walk in someone's shoes.
It's saying, I'm going
to figure out what
it would be like to be them.
I'm going to imagine what
And that builds the
caring and the empathy.
But I can't make
that decision to make
that notion of figuring out what
it would be like to be them.
I'm not going to make that
decision until I first
have understanding that I need
to do that because people want
to talk a lot
about the solutions
you all have done a great
job here because you've
been willing to
identify the problems
and the challenges first.
Giving people solutions that
they don't think they need
doesn't make much difference.
Defining that there might be a
need first in convincing people
is essential to
the conversation.
You all have done, I want to
say, an excellent job of really
working on these pieces of the
puzzle, not just in this one,
but in all these conversations.
It's a courageous thing to do.
Google's best place to
also put things into action
beyond the conversation.
Bravo for this dialogue.
What could be better
as an initial step?
But the technology that
can be utilized and honed
to change things, the access
to individuals out there
in the great beyond who can
see various images, that's
extraordinary power.
And what better place than
this to have that happen.
MICHAEL SKOLNIK: So I
would say, in closing,
I often find myself
preaching to the choir.
But I also know that
the choir has to be fed.
And I hope, we hope, that this
session gave us some good food,
some vegan treats,
healthy snacks because you
do have 20% that as
Kimberly alludes to,
I have no idea who
is in this room.
I have no idea who is
watching across the world.
But I do not go on
Google 47 times a day.
So whatever you all have
created as a user is working.
And you have in genius and
innovation and disruption
in this company that
allows you to take that 20%
and do what you
wish with that time.
And someone in this room could
be fed from this conversation
to then go create something
that could change the trajectory
of my child's life.
That's real talk.
That's not hyperbole.
My child goes to the TV screen
and does this on the TV screen
thinking it's his device
from another company
that you do this with.
[INAUDIBLE] imagine.
But he's four.
And he thinks this is how
you turn on a television.
So already technology
is implanted in his head
how things work.
And you are creating that
technology to change his life.
So thank you to Google
for this conversation.
But most importantly,
thank you to Kimberly
for coming across the country
and joining us and giving us
that food and that health, that
nourishment that we need so
desperately during these times.
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]